up until about midnight last night I
didn't know that there was more than one
Saint Francis so I could talk louder oh
okay well anyway um this is okay while
back some of you found out recently that
I had been in a shelter due to
circumstances beyond my control at the
time at one point I did get out of the
shelter and I was considered under
employed I had a little one-room
apartment and it was it was ok but in
that time frame i was able to i
qualified for the local food banks and
most of them were two churches in the
Waterbury area in the perceptions of
people when you're when you qualify for
a food bank you have all your
documentation you know how much your
income is how much your rent is any
other expenses there are two stories
that came to mind that our most
prominent in that time frame one was the
day I was scheduled to work and there
was a local church who gave an abundant
amount of food bank and it was really to
my advantage to not go to work get war
in the food bank and it was for a three
hour shift but I did my duty I went off
to work and I'm sitting on the bus and
we're going past this church and there's
this woman on the bus and she turns and
she points to the people standing in
line and she says most of those people
are working they should not be there
taking getting food I wanted to say
something my taurus the bull Russian
ancestry wanted to come out and say how
dare you say that I should be there too
but I'm going off to work and I would
get more out of the food bank than I
would with my three hour shift but i bet
my time that I let her ramble and
ramble there were other people on the
bus and most of them just sitting quiet
and as I looked at them I realized quite
possibly those people also qualify for
the food bank we just left this woman
ramble she was making a judgment but
then I was looking at her and wasn't I'm
making a judgment to her or was I merely
assessing her to this day I don't know
the other story was there was a local
Spanish church and I went for the food
bank and i found out that nobody there
spoke English I was and I knew no
Spanish it's been years since I had had
high school Spanish so I've go and
perceived my documents and they look at
him and everything's fine and this woman
was trying to ask me something and I
didn't know what she was saying finally
they found somebody working way in the
back and he comes up to me and he goes
little English I went good little
espanol we proceeded was a basic guide
of the food bank where they had
everything set up in the basement of the
church and he proceeded to ask me some
questions and did I have any children
yes but my daughter was on her own does
she come to visit does she have a baby
do you need you need formula Genie baby
food no no I just I'm here for what I
need do you need diapers do you know
anybody that needs anything no I'm just
here thing he proceeded to show me the
breads and asked me if I wanted bananas
and plantation and I never had plan
change but hey no I'll try it I found
out I can't cook like a restaurant cooks
like those
but it was interesting here if they were
I knew knows virtually no Spanish they
did in English and they were sharing
they wanted to give more and I didn't
need that I didn't need what they want I
just wanted to take what I qualified for
what I could carry back home in my
backpack and to this day that is one of
the most remarkable every time I go past
that church I just have a smile because
they were so kind and and I thought it
was kind of appropriate because with
world community center because they it
wasn't just it was a Spanish community
and you know they really wanted to pour
out their hearts they weren't judging me
they weren't saying well you don't speak
Spanish so we're not going to give you
any food they were just willing to give
me more more than I could handle but
that's just what I wanted to share
good morning before I begin I'd like to
introduce myself just very briefly my
name is William mckinney and i just
recently graduated with my masters in
urban education i'm also a member of the
liturgical ministries group here and am
working as the lead math teacher at
cross connecticut Scholars Academy here
in New Haven now why may have attended
graduate school here at Yale my
undergraduate experiences were vastly
different than probably everyone in this
room because I went to a public
university in the South unc chapel hill
where we like to say worth like hey
y'all and wow you're a hot mess so so my
experiences have been very different but
there is one thing that I think is
probably common from all of us and that
is that that our undergraduate
experiences were some of the best in our
lives they provided opportunity after
opportunity for me to travel and to
learn and to explore and while I could
talk to you all all day about how
awesome Carolina was I was actually
asked to focus and to narrow it down to
preaching the gospel without words so
today's world communion sunday and
although we as world citizens all speak
different languages and experience
Christ differently Christians throughout
the world share a common love that's
experienced through the Eucharist and
I'm going to get to that in a minute so
if you can try and picture me about
three years younger aamir junior at
Carolina and this is where my story is
going to start today I just traveled
about 3,500 miles to the small village
of taka Shia in Bolivia which is located
in one of the most elevated regions in
Bolivia not too far from la paz which is
actually the highest capital
the world and here I had every intention
in the world to assist in the
construction of an orphanage the group I
had been traveling with had been divided
into teams and lucky me i had been to
put on to the brick lang team now i'll
be honest brick lang was not one of my
favorite things to do because when i was
in high school my dad actually had my
two brothers and I collects bricks for
various projects at our house and for
some reason he was never able to figure
out what he wanted to do with the bricks
so we would spend countless saturdays
moving bricks from one side of our house
to the other side because he was like oh
we're going to do this project and then
we wouldn't but then we were going to do
another project on the other side of the
house so we're actually moving hundreds
and hundreds of bricks from one side to
the other nothing actually ever came up
those bricks we threw them away so
needless to say I wasn't super pleased
without having to be on the bricklaying
team and i'm now sitting on a small
plank of wood kind of at the top of this
large hill which is out looking probably
the most gorgeous scenery I've ever been
a scene and Here I am sitting with
partner getting ready to lay bricks
so my partner and I boat neither of us
were actually very excited but we were
excited by the fact that we had managed
to lay for rose full for four rows of
bricks in probably a pretty quick amount
of time and we were all excited and that
excitement just made us so happy until
the inspector came to look at our
progress and he asked us how we were
doing and we said well we got four rows
down already and he was like yeah it
looks good except for one thing I don't
know if you can tell from the side
you're on but from the outside there's a
slight lean and we had no idea what he
was talking about because from our side
it did it looked perfect and so we
peaked their heads over and sure enough
there was a lien which can of course
ruin a building destroy the integrity of
it so we had to start over and we were
like okay fine we were a little
discouraged about it but we progressed
we got more tools more equipment and
took a little bit more time we're a
little bit more cautious and when we
looked at our finished product to four
rows which is what we needed before we
got inspection we were just beaming
smiles beaming from ear to ear we were
so excited and he came back over and
asked how we were doing and we were like
well it's a lot straighter this time and
he looks down at it and he goes your
work looks awesome but and the smiles
just began to waver a little bit just to
hold it and he turns and asks us how
long did it take you to lay these bricks
well we went slower this time to make
sure we got them all straight and he
said or he turned to us and walked
toward the wall and said the thing about
laying bricks is you don't want to go
too quickly because then your work could
end up sloppy but you don't want to work
too slowly either because then the
cement dries before
the brick gets a chance to it here we
had no idea what he was talking about it
looked perfect what could he possibly be
talking about then he reaches down and
lifts up and three rows get lifted up so
he's holding about thirty large bricks
which I have no idea how he was able to
lift that much weight but he did it and
those three rows were stuck together but
we had spent so much time on our second
row trying to get it perfectly lined up
with the first row that the cement had
dried too much before we had laid the
actual bricks down so we had three rows
that were perfect but they weren't
attached to anything so I got to be
honest now I'm a little bit more
discouraged two failures one day wasn't
used to it and here I was i traveled
3,500 miles expecting to make a
difference in this community and my work
had been pretty much useless so at this
point of my day I'm just waiting for a
change I knew I needed to either become
a master bricklayer really quickly or I
could just change to something I was
better at lucky for me school had just
gotten out and all of the village
children were flocking back into the
village with their shouts of joy and
complete enthusiasm now as I said this
was an orphanage so many of these
children had already lost their parents
or were about to lose their parents to
sickness or to illness or her old age
matter when these children had
experienced something tragic and yet
they still brought joy in a sense of
wonder to everyone who was there so
naturally having the day I was having i
retired from my bricklaying post and I
played with the children what was their
favorite game soccer of course now taka
chia is in the mountains of one of the
highest countries in the world
which makes breathing incredibly
difficult so naturally the kids
destroyed us and they were literally
running circles around us as we were
like give us a minute but we all had fun
and the children enjoyed it and it was
that that meant the most of the children
the attention and the love that was
being shared sure the new buildings were
going to be important for their futures
and for their well-being physical
well-being but each child had even
greater emotional needs they had
experienced trauma and they wanted to be
loved now although I would later find
success with floor laying it was in that
earlier moment that I realized I will
never be a construction worker and that
were do any kind of work in construction
but it was also in that moment that I
had realized that what I had expected
going into the trip was going to be
vastly different than what I was
actually experiencing I went into the
truth expecting to make a difference in
the lives of the children I didn't
realize how much they would impact me
how much they would impact my life the
kids could care less that I had two
failures that day they could care less
that I couldn't build a brick wall all I
cared about was the fact that I seem to
have this crazy ability to pick them up
under the arms and spin feverishly
around in circles for long periods of
time without getting dizzy I came on
this trip to help others but the love of
the children definitely went out and
proved so much more some people on the
trip spoke Spanish really well others
were awesome at construction I on the
other hand had a way with children and
my helicopter skills didn't hurt during
this trip we learned that we must each
celebrate our own gifts on our last
evening in taka Chia my group
participated in communion with the
villagers they thanked us graciously for
all we had done and opened their table
generously to us it was here that I
experienced perhaps one of the most
moving celebrations of
Grist everyone gathered in front of the
table in two lines then in groups of two
we literally bet each other Body of
Christ and the blood of Christ actually
putting the bread into each other's
mouths and pouring a small glass of
grape juice in as well it was a bit
uncomfortable but we got used to it it
didn't matter that we couldn't always
understand what was being said for in
that moment we all knew what we were
trying to say to each other in that
moment we were the universal body of
Christ in that moment we were reminded
of the love and passion we had each
experienced in that week in that moment
each of my group realized how much we
had learned about the community and the
love that transcends language
nationality and all other barriers today
is world communion sunday and I hope
that as we partake in the elements
everyone has a chance to feel the
universal body of Christ at work for no
matter the language and no matter the
way in which we celebrate the message is
the same we are all beloved children of
God amen